We can now use our
escapedParameters method and
concatenate its result with
the rest of the URL for
the Flickr API and I'll go ahead and
turn this string into an NSURL object.
But unlike before, we're not going to
make a request using an NSURL.
Instead we're going to use
an NSURL request object,
which is a class that we can wrap around
an NSURL and we can do it like so.
By wrap, I mean that we can create
an NSURLRequest from an NSURL and
then it allows us to have access
to more of the request options.
For instance, we have access
to the request.HTTPMethod.
Now I haven't mentioned HTTP methods in
awhile, but remember, this is a term for
the type of request that's being made.
And for this request,
we're going to use the HTTPGet method.
But since get is the default method,
we don't actually have to
do anything with this particular
property, we don't need to change it.
I should also mention that
when we're using NSURLRequest,
we actually can't change it.
But there is a different class called
NSMutableURLRequests that gives us more
configurability for the request itself
and allow us to change the HTTP method,
for instance, but we're not going to
use that until later in this course.
Now with our request object,
we can use the shared NSURLSession and
the data task with request
method to make our data task and
it takes that same trailing closure with
the data response and error parameters.
And I'll say, if there's no errors
than let's just print the data and
also we'll need to remember to resume
the task for the task to actually start.
Now, let's run the project.
Grab an image.
What's up with this output.
It doesn't look like the JSON we've
seen before in the API Explorer.
There's a reason for this and
let's tackle it next.